I did a video a couple of days ago
about how to throw a bucket of water at someone.
I got a couple of complaints about that,
mainly about me falling in the pool at the end.
A couple of people complained that my acting was terrible.
It was.
A couple of people claimed that the push was obviously faked and scripted.
It was, because anyone who would push someone into a pool without their permission is an absolute jerk,
and I wouldn't want to hang around with them,
but no-one picked up on the real obvious clue it was fake.
Not even the underwater camera shot that didn't have a camera in the wider angle.
No, the reason is if you actually try and push someone into a pool it doesn't look like that.
You push someone into a pool
they're not going to want to go in:
priority one, don't go in the pool,
priority two, keep your head above water.
So, it tends to be sort of a half stagger and then a bounce,
and then they come out dry from here upwards.
You push someone into a pool in the movies or on TV though,
and it looks a little bit something like this.
Go, Hadley!
The difference is--
he says, retrieving the new camera--
I went in back first,
as low as I could go,
as much 'umph' as I can manage going under water,
and then, you can see that I actually keep myself under water:
my arms are pedalling the wrong way,
because it looks way more impressive if I'm under water for a couple more seconds than I actually would be.
Anyone sensible,
anyone who's actually intending to get thrown into the water,
wouldn't stay under, they'd barely go under at all,
their hair might even be entirely dry.
But you push someone into a pool in television:
you need to convince the audience that it's a big splash,
that it's a big under water 'boomph' that sends them all the way down.
In reality, as ever, it's not nearly as impressive.
And that is something you might not know.
And now,  here are all the other takes of me getting pushed into the pool.
If you're doing this, make sure there's enough distance
between the person you're throwing in and the edge of the pool.
You want to wait for the go signal next time?
Sorry!
[Closed captions by MM.
Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]
Towel?
Yes, please.